men are often demonized in the first
session of coup's therapy there are two
big reasons for this one women are
usually better at articulating their
grievances to criticize a woman too
early and she is likely to stomp out of
the session men will just take it six
years for a master's degree then three
years of focused apprenticeship under
other clinicians to become a licensed
marriage family therapist Nye experience
and I remember the training they gave us
about be careful with female clients in
couples therapy because they have come
in expecting that their feelings will be
validated don't smother and stomp on the
guy cuz all of you guys will do that the
woman will be better at crying about her
feelings he never loved me he never
cared and he's like I'm really sorry
that you're having these feelings and
then the therapist is like well this is
the direction you guys want to go cool
hey guy here's the things you must do if
you want to be a decent and then it just
turns into this big Fest about let's fix
the guy meanwhile the things she's
contributing go completely under the rug
the guys are exhausted by this there's a
reason they don't want to go to coup's
therapy anymore